so due to the success of last year's
video i thought it was about time to
revisit the top five most promising
anti-aging compounds especially because
new science has been published in the
last year and my opinions have changed a
bit somewhat slightly and yeah a lot can
happen in a year and so i want this
video to be as up-to-date as possible
and it can be challenging to make such a
list as there are more than 200 proposed
jury protectors to choose from and so if
something isn't included that's not to
say that i've not disregarded it another
quick thing i got a lot of comments last
year saying that vitamins should be on
my list my response is that vitamins are
defined as essential micronutrients your
body needs for proper functioning so
take vitamins as a given
another thing here i refer to anti-aging
as delaying or reversing biological
aging by targeting established molecular
mechanisms of aging i'll explain which
molecular mechanisms as we go through it
as i think it's always important to
understand how different proposed
components are supposed to be working at
least that's my biased biochemist
opinion and there will be timestamps so
you can jump around so okay enough intro
now for the list in no particular order
so firstly unchanged from last year is
alpha ketoglutarate otherwise known as
akg now it was only this week that i
made a video showing some recent
announcements that akg seemed to refer
to the epigenetic age of participants
taking it on average for seven months
whilst this data looks impressive i did
highlight some missing information from
the study but fortunately other human
clinical trials are in the works that
will analyze more measurements for
example i spoke to brian kennedy earlier
this year who was conducting a trial in
singapore they will also take other
measurements besides epigenetic age
including inflammatory markers pulse
wave velocity and also looking at facial
aging and so akg itself is a really
important metabolites found within our
bodies
in particular it's found in the krebs
cycle but it can also activate different
enzymes and as a component of amino acid
biosynthesis in the body as well as
activating different enzymes that can
alter epigenetic marks and a lot of this
work builds upon a 2020 study that
showed that akg supplementation improved
both the lifespan and health span of
mice now whilst the exact molecular
mechanisms are still unclear in terms of
why boosting akg seems to have
beneficial effects i added it to my list
based on the fact that there are
clinical trials in progress and so far
the compound itself is generally
recognized as safe
it's important to say though that so far
this has been testing the calcium salt
version of akg
second on my list is rapamycin and
rapidlogs rapamycin inhibits the protein
mtor which literally stands for
mammalian target of rapamycin
now mtor in the body does many things
but one of them is to promote cellular
growth and so let's thought by
inhibiting emitter activity it can
switch the cell's state from greyfriend
proliferation to a more protective state
where it can upregulate processes such
as autophagy which help to break down
damaged and dysfunctional cell
components and recycle them for the cell
in terms of its anti-aging potential
it's worth mentioning that rapamycin was
tested by the national institute on
aging interventions testing program and
was shown to extend lifespan in both
males and female mice even when it was
done intermittently and even when it was
done later in their lifespan
and more on from that there's also a
human clinical trial being announced the
pearl trial that will study the
anti-aging potential of rapamycin and
you may recall that i recently spoke
with dr brad stanfield who's also in the
works of conducting a human clinical
trial to test rapamycin in addition to
exercise
moreover rapamycin is already fda
approved and is used as an
immunosuppressant drug
and so we already have a lot of data
from humans as to safe doses to use in
human patients
however this is why it'd be interesting
to see the data from these trials to see
if there are any concerns with taking it
for longer time periods
it is worth mentioning though that safer
ways to inhibit temtor may come through
fasting strategies
or by reducing calorie intake and you
can find more about that and safety
concerns in this video here
but all in all given that mtor signaling
seems to be a recurrent feature of many
pathways of aging i definitely think the
use of rapamycin can be considered
promising
next up are nad plus precursors such as
nmn nicotinamide mononucleotides and our
nicotinamide riboside and niacin
given the importance of nad plus to our
bodies as both a redox coenzyme
important for metabolism and as a
substrate for different nad plus
consuming enzymes and that's a reduction
of nad plus in different tissues is
thought to decline of age the impact of
these precursors is interesting to
understand i have a really good video
already well if i do say so myself on
nad plus metabolism that would
definitely be worth watching after this
video if you haven't already as we go
into way more detail there in terms of
the molecular underpinnings but to
summarize here increasing nad plus has
been shown to extend lifespan and
different model organisms
however more recently studies conducted
by the interventions testing program
have shown that nicotinamide riboside
didn't actually extend lifespan but
there's also been many studies that have
looked at the potential of these
precursors to alleviate symptoms of
different age-associated conditions
in different muscle organisms increasing
nad plus has been shown to protect
against age-related declines in
mitochondrial dysfunction physical
performance muscle regeneration and
decline scene and vision
and interestingly clinical trials in
humans have also been announced and are
in progress to look at other things such
as the impact of these precursors on
exercise and cognitive performance it's
worth mentioning that nad plus
precursors can be found in your diet for
example anime can be found in broccoli
and avocados and niacin can be found in
tuna and salmon albeit these are at much
lower amounts than are used in these
different animal studies
but given the interest around these
precursors at the moment and the fact
that clinical trials are in progress
however if you have to see any data for
the use of these precursors that's been
published regarding aging itself i
thought it was mentioning it on our list
as i'm sure we'll find out more
information in the coming year
next up on my list is spermadine
and spermadine is a naturally occurring
polyamine which means it has many
different amino groups and the
interesting thing about these groups is
that it gives spermadine a positive
charge so that it can interact with dna
rna and some proteins that have a
negative charge this ability of
spermatine to bind various components
has led it to be linked with various
cellular processes
in terms of longevity the one that is
most frequently cited is the ability of
spermadine to promote autophagy the
process i mentioned earlier that can
remove unnecessary or dysfunctional
cellular components
it's been shown in yeast that
supplementation of spermadine promotes
longevity for your activation of
autophagy and since then it's also been
shown that spermadine extends lifespan
in worms flies and mice
so what about humans
well based on food questionnaires people
who consume higher dietary levels of
spermadine were associated with reduced
blood pressure and the lower incidence
of cardiovascular disease
and then earlier this year another study
came out that correlated human dietary
consumption here using data from the
brunec study with enhanced cognition and
reduced risk of cognitive impairment
now these human studies are purely
correlation not causation so it's
important to bear that in mind a small
randomized controlled clinical trial has
been done showing improvements in
cognition after three months and other
trials are in progress and we'll look at
a variety of markers and i'll put the
link to that in the description
so where does bermadine come from well
interestingly spermadine is something
our cells can already synthesize but
there are two other ways we can get
spermadine secondly through bacteria in
our guts that can generate spermatine
and lastly as kind of alluded to through
our diet spamadin rich foods include
wheat jam which i've never eaten natto
soy beans cheese mushrooms and peas now
depending on how you process your foods
before eating and what you eat you may
already be consuming around 5 milligrams
to 26 milligrams per day so whilst there
are supplements available i think in the
majority of cases so far
there'll be no reason to supplement plus
unlike with akg there is very limited
human data available to see whether
spermadine supplementation can improve
different aging biomarkers but given
that it's something we already can
consume and isn't apparently toxic i
thought it should be on my list
and then lastly i've chosen metformin
why well for similar reasons to the
others it's been shown to increase
lifespan in different muscle organisms
albeit it didn't extend lifespan mice
tested by the interventions testing
program
metformin is already fda approved and
prescribed for type 2 diabetes and
polycystic ovary syndrome in terms of
human data for aging i think still the
most striking data comes from this 2014
study that showed patients with type 2
diabetes taking metformin had longer
survival than did match non-diabetic
controls
my reservations are with understanding
exactly how metformin is functioning
within the body and somehow activating
this protein amp kinase which can
impinge on mtor signaling that we saw
earlier
also with the side effects i'm working
out the correct dosing and timing but
these are something that randomized
control clinical trials can assess
and in particular a troll to test
metformin for aging the targeting agent
with metformin team trial is still in
the works and hopefully soon that trial
can get started to give us some more
data to really evaluate the efficacy of
metformin
so there you have it my five current
most promising anti-aging compounds
this is my list from last year and this
year so as you can see it has changed
slightly but my mind hasn't changed too
much
importantly none of this is advice just
my scientific understanding and fun
opinion on them as i've honestly not had
a chance to read every single study ever
conducted on all the different reported
duro protectors so if you want list your
top five below it's always interesting
to read your comments and i'll see you
back here with another list in 2022
so with that i hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening
you